wild card weekend starts on saturday and
what we've done every friday all season
long our draft of the folks under the
most pressure
in the weekend to come four games eight
teams and the trivia question determines
who gets the first pick big cat the
houston texans have won three playoff
games in their history each with a
different starting quarterback name two
of those three starting quarterbacks
matt shobb
tj yates
[Music]
you want to go for the trifecta
uh is sean watson not one
no no
no
rock osweiler baby brock lobster oh yeah
against the raiders
yes
yes
listen all these all these texans games
just you know go together they just it's
just one long memory tj yate's a hell
though you never forget that guy
remember the game when they got blown
out by the chiefs and didn't jj watt
take a snap at quarterback at one point
remember that a couple of years ago yes
yes
yeah so i'm going to let you get the
first pick no i'm going to give you the
first pick no you go
no you're deferring i won yeah
you kick you choose to kick
you choose to kick i defer all right
uh you choose to kick i'm just doing a
little wallet anderson i'm going to
start with i hop
all right i'll start with
okay go ahead no no i'm just kidding go
ahead
you know i'm gonna this one this one
is not obvious
but who's under pressure
in a playoff game
right the underdog or the favorite who's
got more pressure the favorites under
pressure to go in there and do what
they're supposed to do right
um drew brees has been phenomenal drew
brees turns 41 on january 15th i believe
the last two times drew brees has faced
mike zimmer in the vikings defense he
has not been spectacular 120 yards
passing on a sunday night in 2018 the
saints won the game and he had three
interceptions two interceptions excuse
me in the playoff loss the minneapolis
miracle they were down 17 points they
came roaring back and took the lead late
and put the vikings in position to need
the miracle but the vikings had a big
lead in that game and failed to put the
saints away drew brees has not been drew
brees against the vikings the last two
times he's played them they're seven and
a half point favorites this could be
drew brees last game as a member of the
saints last home game as a member of the
saints we don't know what he's going to
do next year we don't know what the
saints are going to want to do next year
there have been some concerns about his
arm strength his statistics this year
his passer rating highest of his career
but he's been sub 90 his last two times
against the vikings there is pressure on
him to come out and play like he did
that night against the colts i mean and
not that he's going to be 29 or 30 but
he needs to be closer to that you don't
want to give the vikings an opening if
you're drew brees and if drew brees
plays the way he did the last two times
against the vikings there's a chance
there's going to be a little bit of an
opening for kirk cousins to fail to take
advantage of okay okay the good pick not
what i would have gone with but a good
pick i will start mike with a great pick
and that is brian schottenheimer and
pete carroll they are under a lot of
pressure on sunday because
last year the the wild card round they
go to dallas in a game they should have
won where they tried to establish the
run over and over and over again
when they have the potential mvp he's
probably not going to be the mvp but
he's in the running russell wilson one
of the most dynamic players playmakers
in the nfl and they took the ball out of
his hands will that happen again because
you know that the seahawks want to
establish the run i actually joked that
when rashad penny and chris carson got
hurt and out for the year it was
actually a positive for the seahawks
because it almost forces their offensive
philosophy to run through russell wilson
instead of the run game so this will be
the test because if they do this again
if they have another playoff game where
they don't let their best player one of
the best players in all of football
which i know you don't agree with
because you think he's uh no one talks
about him enough i this will be the
pressure test so i'm saying brian
schottenheimer and pete carroll under
pressure on sunday at the link
one look at the unforced error on sunday
night when they tried to get marshawn
lynch out onto the field for that first
and goal from the one and they they did
they didn't know what was going on and
they did personnel groupings and they're
actually practicing that this week you
would think that teams have all of that
mastered by now the fact that the clock
is running the play clock is running and
you got to get your guys out onto the
field i mean it happens so seamlessly
all the time that when it doesn't happen
it's glaring but uh yeah and and i feel
like that ghost of marshawn lynch at the
goal line from five years ago is still
lingering that's the one drawback to
bringing back marshawn lynch and they
get opportunities down near the one
we'll see what they do but they better
be buttoned up and you're right that
playoff game last year inexcusable the
seahawks should have won that game they
should have had a rematch with the rams
and they didn't rely on russell wilson
and now that and they built the team
around russell wilson right you need to
rely on russell wilson i agree with you
that's a good pick that's a good pick
thank you all right next next round for
me
patriots cornerback stefan gilmore guy
that i would have made our defensive
player of the year if he hadn't been
shredded by devante parker in the
dolphins on sunday in a game that would
have given the patriots a pass this
weekend he is either going to be
covering aj brown man up all game or
they're going to double brown and
they'll have stefan gilmore on corey
davis either way
whatever happened last week mike vrable
smart enough to play that film back and
look at what they did in order to get
stefan gilmore off his mark and it may
just be that he got so accustomed to
people not throwing at him he wasn't
ready for people to throw at him but he
needs to have the kind of game that
we've seen from him all year long except
for on sunday in order for the patriots
to have a chance to slow down the
tennessee titans offense and whether it
is a.j brown very underrated rookie
receiver out of mississippi he and dk
metcalf both playing this weekend both
had phenomenal rookie seasons whether
it's brown whether it's davis whoever it
is gilmore needs to play a lot better
than he did against the dolphins if the
patriots want to advance
okay i'll actually stay in that game i
was gonna pick something similar i was
gonna go patriots defense but i'll stay
in that game and i'll go with the
patriots skill position players and
julian edelman and james white and some
of these guys who tom brady trusts in
and he knows that he can throw it to
them on the third and long it's going to
be very important that those guys have
the game of their life because the
margin of for era for the patriots
offense is very very thin and knowing
that you're going up against derek henry
knowing you're going up against an
explosive offense even though it's ryan
tannehill
that is going to be the big test for the
patriots so they're skill players on
offense making the big plays
getting the big you know the big chunk
yardage when it's there making the big
catch making life easy for tom brady
will be the big test on sunday and the
pressure will be on them sorry saturday
night
in that loss to the chiefs one of the
things we showed in the days after that
how the chiefs decided because it was
one week after the game where tom brady
kind of blew a gasket at his young
receivers on the sidelines they doubled
edelman they doubled white and forced
brady to throw the ball to the guys he
doesn't have faith in those are the guys
who are going to need to step up because
the titans if they're smart about it
we'll take away adam and we'll take away
white and say nikhil harry whoever else
is out there you better be able to step
up and earn the trust in the moment of
tom brady and get him to throw you the
ball otherwise that offense is not going
to do anything so another good pick but
i'm feeling very charitable in the new
year another good pick by you i'm going
to finish
where we started we started with the
houston texans trivia question the
houston texans playing in the houston
texans memorial playoff spot early
saturday afternoon deshawn watson owen
won
as a quarterback in the postseason you
do not want that to go to owen two you
do not want that to become your
narrative that you can't win in the post
season and 0-1 becomes 0-2 becomes 0-3
and who knows how deep the hole gets but
it seems like the texans are going to be
in that spot playing every year at some
point desean watson has to bust through
and get a victory and i think the
pressure is on him at home
as the quarterback of the favored team
with the playoff experience in
comparison to josh allen who has none
it's on desean watson especially if will
fuller does not play to lift the texans
over the bills
okay uh all right my last pick that was
kind of a that was a basic pick by you
like whatever it is
wait wait a minute if we had done this
draft without desean watson then we
would have never heard the end of why we
didn't add desean watts and so you got
sometimes you just gotta check the box i
don't think he's really under that much
pressure it's like kirk cousins kirk
cousins under pressure kirk cousins is
what he is desean watson is going to
have a great we don't know we don't know
what desean watson is yet this is how
you shape yourself same thing next week
lamar jackson you know i don't want to
get too far ahead of ourselves he lost
in the playoffs last year he falls to
owen two all of a sudden you know you
get to that point where you become barry
bonds where you can get it done in the
regular season you can't get it done in
the postseason that's all i know about
baseball in the last 30 years but uh
you don't want to to dig that hole that
you then you be if you like the bengals
every time they're in the playoffs oh
yeah i want to play off games since 1990
it becomes a thing it becomes part of
your narrative you don't want that for
watson he's got to end it now don't let
it linger you're talking a little thing
called clutch gene i like where your
head's at mike uh
okay
my last pick is going to be mike florio
mike florio is under pressure on sunday
when he is doing the pre-game show
the what what's the pre-game show called
it's you can watch it on nbc football
night in america it's on during the day
a little confusing but guess what you're
going to watch it because it's mike
florio and his short face in your tv in
your living room before the sunday
afternoon game between the eagles and
the seahawks this is a promo you're
going to watch this game on nbc there's
no better booth than alan chris and mike
floyer is going to be under pressure
because all of america is watching wow
his minnesota vikings get the doors
blown off them so will mike florio be
able to keep
his composure will mike florian be able
to keep his composure will we see tears
from mike florio while the vikings get
absolutely demolished on sunday
afternoon and he has to
have be in everyone in america's living
room be america's host that's what we
call you mike america's host okay thanks
thanks that tells me you had nothing
else and you know i had some i actually
determined
hold on the only other thing i had was
jerry jones will he decide the what will
be the perfect time to fire jason
garrett to maximize the press he's under
pressure that one's far better that
one's fine he's under pressure because
if he does it right now i don't think
that's going to maximize you got to do
it like sunday around
8 30 9 o'clock at night
all right uh
well let's recap
i have drew brees to fund gilmore desean
watson big cat has brian schottenheimer
pete carroll combo patriots offensive
skill position players and for some
reason
me hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports